la priorité des canadiens c'est
l'inflation on vous en parle tous les
jours on apprenait récemment que depuis
2010 9 bell vidéotron et telus était
parvenu à offrir des forfaits en baisse
de 25% depuis deux ans via leur filiale
à rabais comme virgin par exemple dans
le cas de bell cela dit il ya une autre
étude du groupe britannique et bocaux
qui a analysé 6000 forfait dans 230 pays
qui montre que le canada demeure quand
même le des pays du monde où le prix par
gigaoctet est le plus élevé on a plaisir
ce soir de recevoir mirko bibic le pdg
de bce bell canada sur notre plateau
bonsoir monsieur bédié qui vont recevoir
monsieur fillion merci d'être avec nous
quand on voit ces données par gigaoctet
même si on a vu les forfaits baissé
comment ça se fait que c'est toujours
aussi chaud qu'au canada écoutez
monsieur fillon on en parle beaucoup à
l'internât avec mes coéquipiers et je
constate souvent pas tous les jours que
les canadiens veulent une valeur sûre de
leurs fournisseurs et c inclut belle
naturellement soyons ce qu'on leur offre
des réseaux de haute qualité parmi les
maires raisonnement maintenant on a le
réseau notre nouveau réseau 5g la
couverture partout au canada et des prix
qui sont à la baisse à vous avez fait
référence au rapport de statistique
canada en fait le
connaissent les canadiens paient en
moyenne 27 points 5 % de moins qu'ils
ont payé la dernière fois qu'on s'est
vus au tout début de 2020 et c'est
pareil sa mère qualité etc sans
couverture des prix qui sont à la baisse
et je voulais un exemple tout vu un
nouveau forfait 5 g on vient juste de
lancer nouveau des voiliers dont on a
dévoilé nos nouveaux forfaits 5g il ya
deux semaines ça donne aux canadiens un
accès notre réseau des données illimités
accès aux vitesses 5g accès à notre
service en continu crève mobile tout est
inclus à des prix abordables il faut
aussi constater que les canadiens ne
paient pas la plupart de 15 et ne payent
pas les tarifs affichés mais la plupart
des canadiens paient quand même quand on
se compare au monde entier des prix qui
demeure très élevé pourquoi
fondamentalement au canada faut payer
plus cher qu'ailleurs sa cause la
qualité première je pouvais encore avec
vous mais c'est la qualité des services
aller ailleurs et voyez votre la vitesse
de téléchargement les de la vitesse de
téléversement sites importants ces jours
ci dans le conte le sillage de jean
lapeyre de la crise durant la pandémie
les canadiens veulent est de brancher
partout avec un service fiable mais
pourquoi en israël 500 2 gigaoctets
pourquoi en france 41 cents et nous 5 et
72 regarder les forfaits qu on offre des
forfaits à données illimitées vitesse qu
incomparable incomparable la couverture
du pays demain jean ivoula le pays
compte qu'on a qu'on couvre 99% de la
population que canadienne sur un
territoire qui est le deuxième plus
grand traître au monde est-ce que c'est
pas ça le problème dans le fond on a peu
de population pour un énorme c'est la
densité c'est là dedans c'est la densité
c'est la danse très con à pays comme
israël par exemple la forme a pas décidé
nous ce qu'on a fait on a peut-être n'a
pas décidé de deux branches et que les
red river l'urbaine où il ya de la
densité on couvre 99% de la population
canadienne tout partout de laisser aller
c'est un autre crs qui devrait pas quand
même y avoir davantage de concurrence au
canada le crtc a annulé récemment en mai
2021 une baisse des prix de gros de
l'internet une baisse qui aurait permis
à des dizaines de fournisseurs
indépendants de baisser leurs coûts et
de baisser leurs tarifs également
pourquoi pourquoi on n'aurait pas plus
de concurrence plus de petits
fournisseurs qui pourrait affronter les
géants comme belge monsieur finir
beaucoup quand on parle trop souvent
quand on parle de concurrence faut
garder pour regarder l'ensemble de la
concurrence y on se fixe seulement sur
les prix nous aurons des des réseaux
désuète l'ensemble la concurrence et la
qualité des réseaux faut faire
concurrence au niveau de la qualité des
réseaux la couverture des risques des
réseaux et bien sûr les prix donc ce que
le crtc eut la politique au canada c'est
une politique qui encourage les
investissements dans les réseaux on en a
de la concurrence c'est pour ça que vous
voyez
sur notre territoire nous allons couvrir
d'ici la fin de l'année 7.1 millions
d'emplacements avec la fibre optique de
l'atlantique jusqu'aux manitoba c'est
exceptionnel c'est encore on est parmi
les meilleurs au monde en ce qui
concerne le déploiement de la fibre
optique certains de vos concurrents
parler de concurrence déloyale avec jean
par exemple vous même vous avez été
accusé d'être en conflit d'intérêts avec
le président du crtc qu'est ce que vous
répondez quand vous entendez ça
la rencontre auquel vous faites
référence avec le président serbe décès
c'est une rencontre qui datent 2019 le
chouchou j'apprécie je comprends que les
lits rencontre entre les hauts
dirigeants de bell et certains
représentants du gouvernement notoriété
publique la rencontre a été enregistré
selon les règles on n'a pas discuté des
dossiers devant le crtc le monsieur
scott ses présences rdc se prononcer là
dessus la 5g est ce que le déploiement
de la 5g se déroule pour vous au rythme
souhaité
je sais je me trompe pas vous voulez que
80 % des canadiens d'ici la fin de 2020
de paix accès à des services sans jouer
ça j'en suis très fier d'ailleurs on
sait que la dernière fois que je vous ai
vu qu'on s'est rencontrés c'est un beau
studio tout début 2001 à les brusquer
les vieux studio à l'époque il n'y avait
pas de 5 g au canada oui et depuis ce
temps là lundi à la fin d'année dernière
notre et notre réseau
aujourd'hui notre réseau couvre 70% la
population à la fin d'année comme je les
mentionnaient 80% de la population en
deux ans de couvrir 80% de la population
avait creusé un réseau 5 g c'est
impressionnant et
voilà oui je suis très satisfait du
progrès et on attend la décision du
gouvernement du canada qui viendra se
revoir oui vous avez des affaires avec
huawei est ce que si on interdit whaou
est une entreprise de télécommunications
chinoises dans des plans de déploiement
de la 5g au canada est ce que vous
pourriez demander une compensation
gouvernement du caire on verra ce qui va
se passer quand je quand j'ai un quand
je suis entré en poste en 2020 nous
avons fait une décision que pour le 5
juin nous allons faire affaire avec nos
clients et ericsson avec donc règles ni
pour nos réseaux 5 notre réseau 5g les
équipements qu'on utilise sont les
équipements de deux n'est pas au nokia
ericsson donc la question vous et pour
nous c'est une vieille question là et ma
vie voit encore des liens avec huawei
s'est dit on il nous reste encore des
équipements huawei dans notre équipe nos
anciens réseaux mais aucun groupe aucun
équipement qui ce qui est associé à la
5g dernier point de de trimestre en
trimestre bell augmente son dividende
trimestriel en fait à chaque année
encore de 5% cette fois ci la croissance
passe par quoi chez bell votre priorité
de croissance la croissance on voit
depuis depuis 2000 20 depuis creux du
deuxième trimestre de 2020 on voit que
les on livre des résultats positifs dans
tous les segments de nos opérations très
belle croissance au niveau chez bell
mais chez bell mobilité
on voit que les revenus augmentent la
croissance de revenus tirés par thiery
part nous revenus tirés par les services
ont maté de au delà de 6 points 3 % je
crois c'est la plus grosse croissance de
l'industrie c'est très fort du côté des
services résidentiels une coupelle
croissance au niveau des services
internet les les canadiens recherchent
la qualité la fibre optique était
battable donc vous voyez pour nos
services résidentiels internet la
croissance des revenus débat du baiia
est raccord merci beaucoup monsieur
biblique c'est un plaisir de vous
recevoir merci bien merci monsieur
fillon